[Musique]
ici on a un glaçon qui a été préparé par
Dimitri le soigneur des du secteur tapir
ce matin avec du coup un peu de légumes
on peut voir du poireau dedans un petit
peu de fruits un peu de concombre donc
tout ce qui va être un petit peu
appétissant pour nos tapis ce matin
ici nous avons des glaçons de sang qui
ont été préparés par nos soigneurs donc
des glaçons fait à partir de 100 qu'on a
récupéré
de viande qu'on a découpé et en plus ils
ont mis quelques petits bouts de boeuf à
l'intérieur donc tout ça pour distribuer
à nos Lions cette fois-ci qui vont se
donner on espère à cœur joie dessus
[Musique]
on a de la chance d'avoir un parquet
très arboré du coup avec beaucoup de
zones d'ombre du coup ce qui me permet à
nos animaux et bien de tout simplement
s'abriter quand ils en ont envie ou de
prendre le soleil si son envie et il y a
même certains de nos animaux qui ont
même des bassins dans leurs enclos ce
qui leur permet de se rafraîchir alors
bon vouloir
[Musique]